foreign
is from Curious in Atlanta Georgia
I've been married for over 20 years we
have six kids we have a great marriage
we're best friends and love spending
time together
one thing that continues to happen is
that I express that holidays are
important to me that just a small not
last minute not expensive gestures
appreciated a car dinner but almost
every time the occasion is not
celebrated my birthday or anniversary
he's a great guy these things just do
not hit his radar even though I've
calmly told them they are important I
don't understand how a person shelves
all their expectations especially after
they've been expressed and is not hurt
after a happening repeatedly because to
me it's just pretending not to be hurt I
think it's not possible to walk through
life without some expectation I would
say that no one has said it's possible
to walk through life with out
expectations this is actually a coal
response and curious thank you so much
for your question it's very heartfelt
and I can tell that you're you're
struggling right now I have a lot of
compassion for that because I've
certainly struggled with
miscommunications not just in my current
relationship with back Bex and I we
unpack that on her podcast how to love
about some of the miscommunications that
we often have and not fault finding not
blaming the other person but trying to
find the actual fault line that we have
fallen into so to speak and so I think
this is a response to We did an episode
about expectations with Matt Nathanson
and so curious is calling because what
she heard there when I talk about
expectations being a roadblock on the
highway to happiness
what she heard was hey how can I shell
of all of my expectations that's not it
at all just like there's a difference
between asceticism
and Hedonism those are two sort of
terminuses
permanai on the the
sort of consumption Continuum and
minimalism is somewhere in the middle
right because as a minimalist I'm not
saying
don't own anything I'm not saying be an
ascetic I'm not saying abstain from all
worldly pleasures I mean the ascetics
they took it really really far back in
the day they would like sleep on broken
glass and and things to not just try to
remove pleasure from their life but to
become comfortable with severe pain not
saying that that is a great thing to do
right Buddhism they call the middle path
right I would call minimalism the middle
path for consumption because it's not
about living with nothing and it's also
not about embracing every hedonistic
impulse we do a segment and we'll do it
here later on the private podcast we do
the segment about checkout line wisdom
where the the impulses that we often
gravitate toward at a checkout line at a
grocery store a convenience store or a
department store
they often
they try to Peak our interest through
impulse impulse purchase right and these
impulses are also
roadblocks on the highway to happiness
and so curious I'm not telling you that
you should shelve all of your
expectations rather what I'm saying is
as soon as we begin to understand our
expectations and how absurd many of our
expectations are when we start saying
our expectations out loud those
expectations cease to have the same
value that we once assigned to them they
don't have the same Gravity the same
weight that they once had when they were
just hanging out here in our mind we're
creating all these expectations all
these shoulds TK should do this Jordan
no more should do this my wife should do
this these are all expectations I've
created and as soon as I see how absurd
most of my expectations are I can let go
of those expectations or even if they're
still there they don't carry nearly as
much weight
perfectly said I'll just add to that
that
you know curious you you said you know
you've got this wonderful 20-year
marriage you've got six kids together
he's a great guy
that's that's what to focus on right
like you clearly love and appreciate
your husband
and I would assume he clearly loves and
appreciates you what are the ways in
which she shows you that love and
appreciation outside of the specific
ways that you want him to show you that
yeah you know the card on the
anniversary or the birthday
item or you know whatever the the balls
that you feel like he is dropping or the
expectations that you have of him
acknowledging those those special days
are that he's not meeting what are the
other ways in which he shows you that he
really does love you right for example
like
um Josh will frequently bring me coffee
in bed he's up early
you know brings me coffee in bed wakes
me up with a kiss and a cop a cup of
coffee not saying that's the the
standard or anything but that's just
something to me that that that shows me
that he's thinking about me that shows
me he loves me
um what are the things that your husband
does for you that are like that that you
can acknowledge and take pleasure in
instead of looking to the things that
he's clearly not
either able or willing or some
combination of the two
um to meet your needs on the other front
he doesn't care about those things as
much as you do yeah yeah and the problem
is that you think that he should care
about those things and so if we were
doing an episode of How To Love right
now I I would probably have a lot more
tough love with respect to this this
question because we often dish out or
Dole out some tough love on how to love
because we experience tough love and let
me explain what I mean by that if your
expectation backs was that I brought you
coffee in bed every morning it would not
be the same sort of joy for me to
provide that to you because I would
merely be meeting an expectation I I
would be doing the bare minimum in order
to pacify you essentially right and so
curious one thing you might not realize
you're doing right now is you're asking
in some way to be pacified a little bit
here are my expectations and if you meet
them then I will be what what do you
think is going to happen if he meets all
of your expectations I can tell you what
will happen if you have a hundred
expectations and he meets 99 of them
you're going to be discontented about
the one that he does not meet or even
worse he meets all 100 of your
expectations what do you have then you
have absolute certainty what do you get
out of absolute certainty you get
boredom you're going to make your
relationship really really boring if all
you're doing is setting up these
expectations for someone else to meet
and that just that's not just for your
husband by the way that's any other
relationship in your life when we have
all these expectations if they are met a
hundred percent now what I have absolute
certainty that's what hell looks like
hmm
foreign
so there are two aspects I see to
creating a healthy and happy life one
aspect is
learning how to live helpfully and
happily when you can't get what you want
because sometimes reality says no no
matter how bad you want it you gotta
have a philosophy for what am I going to
do during those moments but the second
aspect is how can I give myself the best
chance possible to create the results
that matter
most to me and I want to speak to that
second part because I do think that
first part is important I do think it's
valuable for you to give your husband
permission to be whoever and however he
needs to be without
giving that the power to ruin your day
or your holiday
but one of the things you said was I've
said this over and over again I've made
this clear and it's clear like that he
doesn't hear or that he doesn't get it
this is a very common challenge in
relationships by the way and one of the
reasons this is a challenge is because
when you talk to him about what matters
to you you're speaking from a place of
conviction and you rarely have to use
your memory when you're speaking from
that place you're not following an
externally imposed rule that someone
gave to you you're just speaking about
what makes you feel Joy and you're
asking him to remember that because he
has different convictions than you
different interests than you he's going
to have to take that on as a kind of
external rule to follow not necessarily
legalistically but it's something that
he has to remember right and that means
it's going to be harder for him to hang
on to that automatically than it is for
you and so having to remind him having
to bring it up multiple times is
something that it would be good to be
prepared for even if you are successful
in the end just I would adjust my
expectation in that way did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private a podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free